Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass, ein historischer Moment in der Rasenfunk-Geschichte. Der Rasenfunk schickt eine eigene Reporterin zur Frauen-Wm! Wie? Warum? Wieso? Weshalb? Was muss ich dafür tun? Ihr erfahrt es jetzt gleich hier im Kurzpass. Und damit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, übergebe ich den Staffelstab an Frank. Frank, hallo!
Was macht der denn hier? Na ja, wir haben uns überlegt, eigentlich wär's ganz gut, wenn ich so ein bisschen den Stab des Handelns in die Hand nehme in dieser Sendung, weil, wie ihr euch natürlich denken könnt, ihr habt gehört, es geht um die Frauen-Wm. Ihr könnt's ahnen, ich werde zur Frauen-Wm inhaltlich relativ wenig beitragen. Aber die beiden anderen, die jetzt bei mir an der Sendung sind, umso mehr, nämlich einerseits der Max, den habt ihr gerade schon gehört, und andererseits diejenige, die wir, wie Max im Intro angekündigt hat, zur Wm. schicken. Hallo Annika, Annika Becker.
Wuhu, ich späte dir einen Applaus ein, ich hätte mir das aufs Aufbau legen sollen.
Annika, ganz herzlich willkommen. Du wirst also diejenige sein, die für den Rasenfunk zur Frauen-Wm. fährt. Und für all diejenigen, die es nicht wissen, die Frauen-Wm. findet in Australien und Neuseeland statt. Ganz schön weit, erzähl uns doch vielleicht mal kurz, wer du bist, wie man dich kennen könnte und wie es dazu kam.
Ja, also ich bin Annika Becker. Einige von euch kennen mich wahrscheinlich aus dem Rasenfunk tatsächlich. Ich habe angefangen, vor ein paar Jahren ganz normal über Fußball zu bloggen und zu podcasten. Die erste Einladung kam von Karsten in die Halbfeldflanke. Seit ungefähr zwei Jahren bin ich aber tatsächlich freiberufliche Journalistin. Ich fokussiere mich sehr stark auf den Fußball der Frauen, berichte sehr viel über die Bundesliga. Zum Beispiel mache ich ganz oft die Vorberichte für sportschau.de oder auch für OneFootball, schreibe Kolumnen und so weiter. Ich habe seit Kurzem auch einen eigenen Podcast zusammen mit Mara Pfeiffer. Da könntet ihr mich darüber kennen. Wie gesagt, ich mache sehr viel zum Fußball der Frauen. Ich habe letztes Jahr auch die EM begleitet, da noch nicht von vor Ort, sondern von zu Hause. Ich habe in meinem Blog ein EM-Tagebuch gehabt und immer geguckt, was sind die Themen des Tages, was ist das größere Ding, über das man gerade sprechen kann, wie ist die Berichterstattung usw.
Super, ich habe ein bisschen schmunzeln müssen, als du gesagt hast, ich habe ganz normal angefangen über Fußball zu glocken. Wunderbar, als wäre es das Normalste der Welt. Und es ist natürlich auch für fußballverrückte Menschen wie dich, wie Max und wie viele unserer Hörer wunderbar. Max, jetzt ist ja dieses WM-Thema bei uns ohnehin groß gewesen schon vorher. Aber wie blickst du denn jetzt darauf? Wie kam es denn aus deiner Sicht dazu, dass wir jetzt plötzlich jemanden zu einem Turnier schicken, was, wie du es im Intro schon gesagt hast, natürlich eine komplette Neuerung ist für den Rasenfunk?
Also ich würde sagen, nicht wir sind darin schuld, sondern die Gegebenheiten, die aber, glaube ich, etwas sehr Positives befördern. Also ich freue mich da extrem über, dass wir das jetzt wagen. Das ist ja für uns auch ein Risiko. Dadurch, dass die Frauen-WM in Australien und Neuseeland stattfindet, was jetzt von hier aus gesehen nicht ein Katzensprung ist. Ich musste vorhin schmunzeln, als du gesagt hast, Annika fährt für uns zur WM. Ich glaube doch, da wird sie dann doch im ersten Schritt weniger. Das hat dazu geführt, dass es gar nicht so viele deutsche Redaktionen gibt, die jemanden vor Ort haben werden. Das ist jetzt schon festzustellen. Also sowohl Annika hat es erlebt, als sie eben schon versucht hat, Auftraggeber zu finden. Und auch andere Journalistinnen haben ähnliche Probleme, dass eben die Reaktion von deutschen Medien eher ist, ich spitze das mal zu. Es interessiert ja vor allem das deutsche Team. Das deutsche Team, da bekommen wir dann auch Sachen von den Agenturen geliefert. Dafür brauchen wir niemanden vor Ort. Und für den Rest lohnt es sich in Anführungszeichen nicht, jemanden hinzuschicken. Das war so die Situation, wie du sie, glaube ich, auch erlebt hast, Annika. Und da wird dann mein Ehrgeiz geweckt und unser Ehrgeiz geweckt. Und so kam das dann zustande. Und das macht dann, glaube ich, auch den besonderen Reiz aus, denn der Rasenfunk wird das sowieso schon mehr zu diesem Turnier machen als viele andere, vielleicht alle anderen Medien. Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist nicht so genau vorherzusehen, was da kommen wird. Und dann aber jetzt dann noch den Luxus zu haben, jemanden vor Ort zu haben und quasi diese Perspektive noch aufzubrechen, die bisher im Rasenfunk immer nur über so Konstruktionen aufgebrochen werden konnte, indem wir eben ReporterInnen von vor Ort mal einzeln eingebunden hatten oder eben zum Beispiel eine Kathrin Schreib bei der Männer WM 2018, Kathrin Schreib natürlich, Entschuldigung, mit eingebunden hatten. Das jetzt quasi noch mal auf so neues Level zu heben, da bin ich, also da kriege ich positives Herzrasen, wenn ich daran denke. Das ist mega.
Ich auf jeden Fall auch, vor allem weil, wie du sagtest, wir haben den Blick bisher zwar immer mal gehabt durch einzelne Gespräche mit Menschen vor Ort, ob das nur eben Kathrin Schreib war oder dann einzelne Reporter anderer Stationen, die wir mal in einer Sendung hatten, aber jetzt so wirklich komplett jemand eigenen vor Ort zu haben, ist schon ziemlich spannend, weil wir ja auch ein bisschen einen Einblick in ein Turnier bekommen, den man vielleicht durch das, was im TV berichtet wird, also natürlich einerseits die Spiele, es ist ja allseits bekannt, dass man, wenn man im Stadion ist, immer andere Dinge sieht als im Fernsehen, aber eben auch außerhalb der Spiele. Was bedeutet denn jetzt dieser Schritt, da jemanden hinzuschicken, auch für die Berichterstattung im Rasenfunk, Max?
Naja, genau diese zusätzliche Ebene, die wird jetzt dann erstmals so wirklich abgedeckt. Also die Berichterstattung, die wird ähnlich sein zu bisherigen Turnieren, sowohl bei Männern als auch jetzt zur letzten Frauen-EM. Das heißt, wir werden natürlich eine Vorschau haben und sehr wahrscheinlich auch einen Rückblick. Und es wird sehr viele Kurzpässe geben eben zu den einzelnen Spielen. Es ist wieder das Ziel des Rasenfunks, das wir jedes Spiel besprechen. Und aber jetzt noch häufiger und noch bunter mit eben Perspektiven vor Ort. Und das ist eben auch etwas, was ich ehrlicherweise im Frauenfußball noch wesentlich interessanter finde als im Männerfußball, wo es schon auch eine Relevanz hat. Wie reagieren die Menschen vor Ort auf dieses Turnier? Wie ist die Stimmung in den Stadien? Wie wird dieses Turnier von der Organisation her wahrgenommen? Und wie erleben auch die Protagonistinnen vor Ort das Turnier? Weil das eben alles auch Themen waren, die waren bei der Frauen-EM viel präsenter als bei Männer-Turnieren, weil es eben da auch um Fragen ging, wie warum spielen wir jetzt in diesem kleinen Stadion? Warum gibt es zu wenig Presseplätze? Wie sind die Bedingungen vor Ort? Wie reagiert auch quasi die Bevölkerung auf dieses Turnier? Ich weiß nicht, Annika, wie du auf dieses Turnier vorausblickst, aber ich habe das Gefühl, wir stehen gerade an so einem Scheideweg, der mit der Frauen-EM einen vorläufigen Höhepunkt hatte. Und da finde ich eben gerade diese Fragen auch unheimlich spannend.
Ja, total. Also ich finde, man merkt es auch gerade so an dieser Vorlaufphase, die wir jetzt haben. Also man hat einerseits die größte Weltmeisterschaft der Frauen, die es bisher gab. Also allein schon von der Anzahl der Teilnehmerländer her. Das sind zum ersten Mal 32. Und es gibt irgendwie sehr viel Vorfreude, glaube ich, in vielen Teilen der Welt auch darauf. Und es wird irgendwie wahrscheinlich auch von den Übertragungen her das größte Turnier sein. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt in Deutschland, wegen der Zeitverschiebung, aber so allgemein. Aber dann hat man andererseits halt diese Kipppunkte, dass gerade viele in vielen Ländern die Nationalspielerinnen protestieren in irgendeiner Form gegen ihre eigenen Verbände, gegen ihre Trainerteams für bessere Bedingungen, weil einfach die Strukturen nicht so gut sind. Da weiß man ja auch noch gar nicht, wie sich das bis dahin in vielen Fällen so entwickelt. Und ich denke aber sehr stark, dass das Themen sind, die uns dann auch zum Turnier selber vor Ort immer wieder begegnen werden, auf die eine oder andere Weise. Also ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass es da in manchen Fällen vielleicht auch Protestaktionen geben wird, zum Beispiel.
Jetzt hat Max mich vorhin ja schon richtigerweise korrigiert. Du wirst natürlich nicht zur Wm! fahren, sondern hinfliegen, logischerweise. Jetzt haben wir eingangs gesagt, Australien und Neuseeland. Du fliegst allerdings nach Australien und wirst auch da bleiben. Du fliegst nicht nach Neuseeland. Was hat denn zu dieser Entscheidung geführt?
Hauptsächlich logistische Gründe. Also wenn man beides machen wollen würde, dann hatte ich halt mir erst so gedacht, na ja, man könnte quasi mit Neuseeland anfangen, während noch die Gruppenphase läuft. Und kurz bevor die zu Ende ist, kann man dann rüber wechseln. Aber es wäre so ein Reiseaufwand, ein zeitlicher Aufwand, wo dann nicht mehr viel Zeit übrig bleiben würde, um tatsächlich Leute zu treffen und mit denen zu sprechen und Themen vorzubereiten. Sondern man wäre halt immer nur unterwegs. Und es ist natürlich auch ein Kostenfaktor. Zumal wenn man sich das dann anguckt, man auch schnell feststellt, dass Neuseeland doch noch mal um einiges teurer ist als Australien.
Also sowohl die Reisekosten zwischen Neuseeland und Australien, als auch die höheren Übernachtungs-
Wenn es überhaupt noch Unterkünfte gibt, also nach dem, was man da gerade so hören kann, dann sind die Neuseeländer da so ein bisschen besorgt, ob das Ansturms der Fans, die da zu erwarten sind. Also Annika, da bist du ja noch tiefer drin als wir, weil du dich quasi schon mit Unterkünften selbst auseinandergesetzt hast. Aber dieser Teil der Wm! könnte eventuell auch ein bisschen chaotisch werden.
Ja, da bin ich tatsächlich auch mal sehr gespannt drauf. Aber es ist da tatsächlich so, dass aus mehreren verschiedenen Gründen, also auch durch die Pandemie, da gerade einfach die ganze Tourismus- und Hotelindustrie in Neuseeland große Probleme zu haben scheint und dass deswegen das nicht bei voller Kapazität läuft. Und dass es da tatsächlich schon so erste Stimmen gibt, die halt sagen, bis zur Wm! könnte alles eng werden.
Wenn du dann nun in Australien bist, was ist denn dein Gedanke? Wie sehen die Inhalte aus, die du denkst für den Rasenfunk zu machen? Was sind die Blickwinkel, auf die du dich da unten freust? Und wo du denkst, dass wir die ganz gut im Rasenfunk platzieren können?
Also erstmal natürlich so, wie die Stimmung vor Ort ist, wie das Turnier eigentlich von den Leuten vor Ort gesehen wird, wie es so im Land ankommt. Ein bisschen vielleicht auch wie die Berichterstattung vor Ort ist. Und dann natürlich auch mal das ein oder andere Spiel sehen zu können. Und davon zu erzählen, wie das eigentlich so ist, wie sich das dann auch so anfühlt, neben taktischen Betrachtungen. Und ja, aber natürlich auch einfach Leute zu treffen und sich mit denen mal zu unterhalten. Es ist ja gerade im australischen Fußball auch sehr, sehr viel los. Da fände ich es halt auch total spannend, da vielleicht mal eine Perspektive von dem einen oder anderen Menschen drauf zu bekommen. Und natürlich auch, wie da dann der Fußball der Frauen gerade so dasteht, in welcher Entwicklungsphase, was da vielleicht gerade so wichtige Themen sind. Also ich glaube, Anknüpfungspunkte gibt es da wirklich mehr als genug. Und ja, da werden wir dann auf jeden Fall vor Ort gute Leute finden, mit denen man sich da unterhalten kann.
Ja, ich glaube auch vor allem als jemand, der in der Thematik nicht ganz so tief drin steckt wie ihr beide, glaube ich auch, dass vor allem der letzte Punkt ganz interessant ist, den Standpunkt oder den Entwicklungsstand des Frauenfußballs in diesem Land, also in Australien, zu sehen, aber natürlich auch wahrscheinlich in der Kommunikation mit Fans aus anderen Ländern ein bisschen zu erfahren, wie es dort jeweils ist. Das sind natürlich schon ganz spannende Blickpunkte, auf die wir uns glaube ich im Rasenfunk auch riesig freuen und auf die sich auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer freuen können, Max. Aber für die und für uns bedeutet dieser große Schritt natürlich auch, und das kann sich jeder vorstellen, wir haben ja schon öfter darüber gesprochen, wir zahlen mittlerweile Gästehonorare an die normalen Gäste in allen anderen Sendungen und natürlich bezahlen wir Annika auch entsprechend ein Honorar für diesen Tritt. Aber obendrauf kommen ja natürlich noch Reisekosten, Übernachtungskosten etc. Für den Rasenfunk bedeutet das auch einen großen Schritt, was den Kostenpunkt angeht. Wie sieht es denn auf dieser Seite aus? Womit müssen wir denn da rechnen und damit ein Stück weit auch die Supporter des Rasenfunks?
Also man kann eine Summe nennen und die wollen wir auch so offen kommunizieren. Wir rechnen damit, dass das ganze Projekt, und da ist Annikas Honorar nur ein kleiner Teil von leider, wird uns 10.000 Euro kosten. Das ist das, mit dem wir kalkulieren, wo wir glauben, dass wir ungefähr hinkommen. Ganz genau ist es natürlich vorher sehr schwer zu sagen. Und das ist aber nicht nur eine hohe Summe für euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, sondern auch für uns. Also das sind 10.000 Euro, die wir stand jetzt noch nicht haben, die wir brauchen. Und weshalb wir da natürlich auch sehr sorgfältig abgewogen haben, ob wir das machen wollen. Aber sowohl bei dir, Frank, ich denke, du solltest da auch gleich nochmal kurz was zu sagen, als auch bei mir ist einfach die Vorfreude auf das, was das bedeuten kann, jemanden vor Ort zu haben und eben auch mit Annika zusammenarbeiten zu dürfen. Das ist auch einfach, also das ist eine sehr große Chance. Und das kann wirklich die Berichterstattung so auf ein anderes Level heben, dass wir sagen, wir sind bereit, dieses Risiko zu gehen und vertrauen dann letztlich auch aber auf unsere Community, die bisher immer da war, wenn wir darum gebeten haben und die dann hoffentlich auch in diesem Fall da sein wird.
Ja, man muss auch dazu sagen, wir haben in der Vergangenheit immer darüber gesprochen, wo will der Rasenfunk eigentlich hin, wie können wir uns weiterentwickeln, wie kann der nächste Schritt aussehen. Und wenn wir ehrlich sind, hatten wir diesen Schritt eigentlich gar nie so wirklich im Blick, jemanden zu einem Turnier zu schicken. Aber als sich die Möglichkeit ergeben hat, waren wir uns relativ schnell einig, das ist was, was wir machen wollen. Das kann ein guter nächster Schritt sein. Das kann ein erstes Mal sein, dem auch weitere Male folgen können. Und der erste Gedanke, den wir hatten, war, wir machen das quasi so ein bisschen als Crowdfunding. Wir gucken, dass wir eine Summe abstecken und dann gehen wir an die Supporter, an die Hörer und Hörerinnen ran und sagen, okay, das wollen wir machen. Und wenn wir den Betrag zusammen haben, dann machen wir es. Jetzt kamen aber zwei Faktoren dazu. Einerseits haben wir gesagt, wir sind uns eigentlich sicher, dass wir es machen wollen. Wir versuchen, einen Weg zu finden, wie wir es auf jeden Fall machen können. Und dann kamen die zeitlichen Komponente dazu, in der uns klar wurde, wir müssen eigentlich möglichst schnell Nägel mit Köpfen machen, weil die Flüge müssen gebucht werden, die Unterkünfte müssen gebucht werden, die ganzen Presseakreditierungen etc., Wir müssen das eigentlich angehen. Und darum haben wir jetzt den Schritt gewagt und haben gesagt, okay, wir machen das auf jeden Fall. Aber wir müssen auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, klar machen, es geht nur mit eurer Unterstützung. Und darum an dieser Stelle die Bitte, wenn ihr den Rasenfunk noch nicht unterstützt, überlegt euch, ob dieses Projekt nicht jetzt ein guter Anlass sein könnte, damit anzufangen. Und wenn ihr uns bereits unterstützt, erstmal vielen Dank. Das ist uns natürlich super viel wert. Und wir freuen uns, dass es so ist. Aber vielleicht nehmt ihr dieses Projekt zum Anlass und findet eine Möglichkeit, den ein oder anderen Euro auf eure hoffentlich regelmäßige Unterstützung obendrauf zu packen.
Genau. Und dann kommt es nämlich auch jenseits dieser Wm! dann eben zu guter. Also wir werden jetzt nicht unterschiedliche Töpfe aufmachen. Das hier ist der Annika Wm!-Topf und das ist der normale Gästehonoratopf. Sondern wir sehen das auch als Möglichkeit nochmal euch darum zu bitten, Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter zu werden. Auch nochmal verbunden mit dem Hinweis, dass ihr selbst ja entscheidet, in welchem finanziellen Umfang ihr das werden möchtet. Also macht das individuell nach dem Value for Value Prinzip. Also welchen Gegenwert hat denn der Rasenfunk für euch? Und jetzt dann eben in dem Fall muss man einmal auch in die Zukunft projizieren, welchen Gegenwert wird der Rasenfunk für mich haben mit einer auch solchen Frauen-Wm!-Berichterstattung? Also ist das eben ein Kinobesuch im Monat, ist das ein Kaffee im Monat oder ist das eben nur der berühmte Euro im Monat, den vielleicht auch Studentinnen und Studenten haben? Aber ich will das gar nicht. Also das müsst ihr für euch entscheiden, aber nehmt das nochmal zum Anlass, das eben zu hinterfragen. Und dann ist es eben toll, wenn ihr eure Unterstützung jetzt dann gleich beginnt. Denn zum einen haben wir jetzt ja dann schon Kosten, die gleich anfallen werden. Frank hat es ja gerade schon genannt. Und zum anderen sehen wir es eben auch als Chance, den Support nochmal ein Stück weit zu steigern, was ja dann auch allen zukünftigen Projekten ebenfalls zu Gute kommt. Ihr wisst ja, wir wollen die Gästehonorare noch erhöhen. Ihr seht ja bestimmt auch, welche Sendungsfrequenz wir inzwischen erreicht haben. Allein dadurch steigen unsere Ausgaben. Und wir haben noch so viele Ideen. Also es wird nicht so sein, dass ihr das Gefühl habt, ich habe jetzt einmal hier für eine Wm-Berichterstattung den Support eingerichtet. Und danach war aber alles wie immer im Rasenfunk. Nee, nee, der Rasenfunk entwickelt sich weiter. Man merkt es ja jetzt schon. Und das wird aber jetzt, ja, das wird noch zunehmen.
Ja, definitiv. Wenn ihr wissen wollt, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, guckt auf unsere Website rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da findet ihr unter anderem unsere Überweisungsdaten oder auch einen Link zu Patreon, wenn das der bessere Weg für euch ist. So als kleiner Hinweis, auf dem Weg der Überweisung kommt am meisten bei uns an. Da gehen keine extra Gebühren für drauf und das hilft uns dann am meisten. Richtet gerne einen Dauerauftrag ein, überweist auch einen einmaligen Betrag, ganz wie es für euch passt. Aber wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr uns bei diesem Projekt unterstützen könnt und vielleicht eure Unterstützung erhöhen könnt. Genau und damit glaube ich eigentlich haben wir fast alles gesagt, was wir zur Frauen-Wm! in Australien und Neuseeland 2023 vorhaben. Wir hoffen, dass es euch gefällt, was wir vorhaben. Dass alles drin war in der Sendung, was euch hoffentlich die Entscheidung erleichtert, uns zu unterstützen bzw. euren Unterstützungsbetrag zu erhöhen. Und ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei Annika Becker, vielen Dank. Wir freuen uns ganz, ganz sehr, dass du da für uns hinfahren wirst und den Rasenfunk damit richtig bereichern wirst. Das wird ganz großartig.
Ich freue mich allein schon auf die Instagram-Stories. Haben wir noch gar nicht drüber geredet, wird es natürlich auch geben. Es wird so fantastisch.
Ach herrje, wir vergessen die Hälfte. Nee, es wird ganz großartig. Ich glaube, es wird sportlich großartig werden. Und wir sind richtig aufgeregt über das, was wir mit dem Rasenfunk dahin gehen machen können. Max, vielen Dank, dass ich mal wieder dabei sein durfte. Und auch noch mit tragende Rolle. Ich hoffe, es war nicht ganz so schlimm für die Hörer und Hörerinnen. Und wir hören uns dann wahrscheinlich ein bisschen später wieder. Denn Max hört dir ganz sicher ganz bald wieder. Und ich sag Dankeschön und bis zum nächsten Mal im Rasenfunk.